c'est quoi la vie d'un tétraplégique
c'est ben lever le matin être souvent
dépendants d'une tierce personne
c'est quasiment toute la matinée en
soins avec
des soins corporels une prévention
cutanées importantes puisqu'il ne
ressentent pas les pressions et les
risques de blessures c'est aussi des
problèmes sur le plan urinaires et et
fécales et ça on le voit pas mais pour
eux c'est un stress de tous les jours
de dire voilà est-ce que l'ag par une
fuite est ce que commande gérer ça aussi
au quotidien
c'est ben mettre deux fois plus de temps
à se préparer à manger s'il le peut
parce qu'il ya certaines qui peuvent pas
qu'ils ont même besoin de quelqu'un pour
les aider à manger c'est se poser la
question toujours quand on part sur les
quand ils partent sur l'extérieur c'est
d'accord est ce que j'ai tout mon
matériel de quoi je veux a besoin est ce
que je vais pouvoir aller parce qu'il ya
l'accessibilité aussi ça soit en
fauteuil manuel ou en fauteuil
électrique
c'est une fatigue engendrée dans la vie
de tous les jours donc bah c'est vrai
que faire la fiesta jusqu'à 3h du mat
bah ouais faut s'organiser aussi
oui je pense que forcément
on est plus sensibilisé parce qu'on voit
le résultat des accidents de la route
et c'est vrai que je pense que là on
parle de déformation professionnelle des
fois mais dans ma vie de tous les jours
voilà je sais que je fais des remarques
à des proches ou à des gens avec qui
suit et je suis peut-être perdu en plus
attentive aux motards parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a un nombre de motards quand
même important sur le terme d' accidents
de la route
ou alors de circonstance aux accidents
l'alcool est quand même souvent
en lien avec les accidents et et c'est
vrai quoi ça ça sensibilise dans sa vie
de tous les jours aussi parce qu'on voit
le résultat
et quand on en parle avec les autres
fermeraient fera peut-être qu'on aille
voir ce que ça fait on comprendrait
mieux quoi